les voyageurs terrestres ont désormais
droit à une seconde chance je les fais
pour moi ma mère et mon fils par contre
j arrive et ils m'ont rien demandé et en
plus ma mère l a pas un téléphone
smartphone a là aussi j'étais pas avec
elle alors été pas mal la re
[Musique]
max
25 à 30 % des voyageurs ne remplissent
pas les informations correctement sur
l'application arif cannes
conséquence de gros ralentissements aux
frontières terrestres ottawa a donc
assoupli les règles plus d'isolement de
14 jours ni d'amande pour les voyageurs
qui oublie de remplir l'application arif
cannes une première fois le ministère de
la sécurité publique fédérale n'a pas
retourné nos demandes d'entrevue mais
chez certains douaniers on comprend mal
ces changements sur 800 actions avec
l'application iphone on voit mal
l'utilité de garder l'obligation de
t'avoir 7 arrive quand arrive kahn est
entré en vigueur au printemps 2020
l'application visait à mieux contrôler
le plan de quarantaine des voyageurs
rentrant au pays c'est très difficile
d'avoir encore une utilité en 2022
l'idée en santé publique d'avoir un
contrôle à la frontière pour empêcher
une maladie de rentrer là du sens dans
le contexte où la maladie existe plus
bas à l'intérieur des frontières et
qu'en pensent les voyageurs avec les
deux axes et je pense que ça ne sert
plus à rien mais se passer pour la
protection du canada des gens de nous
tous c'est mon garçon qui vont montrer
comment faire je travaille régulièrement
ici le chabab viable à remplir mais je
trouve c'est une perte de temps énorme
malgré ces nouveaux assouplissements
pour les voyageurs ce n'est pas la fin
de l'utilisation de l'application arif
cannes elle est toujours pleinement en
vigueur dans les aéroports ici marc
isabelle roche en rade au canada
montréal